and finally new rules someone has to
tell me how it is that for most consumer
products there's such stiff competition
that a common sales pitch is if you find
this item at a lower price come on in
and we'll beat it but a knee replacement
can cost
seventeen thousand in one hospital and
61 grand in another in the same city
with most products you as the consumer
get lucky and there's no possible way to
gouge you like that and that's when you
hear since it would be in anyone's
advertised price are your backers
that's how capitalism is supposed to
work a weirdo in a bad suit pledging
he'll kill his whole family before he's
under sold but that doesn't apply to the
big-ticket items like the Pentagon and
hospitals an infrastructure where
everyone gets to wet their beak before
anything gets done and that's why
nothing ever does get done well can't we
help the homeless if you look around
this city lately you probably are saying
to yourself either the homeless problem
is getting worse or camping isn't what
it used to be
you know after World War two there was a
huge housing shortage in LA when all the
vets returned home and had nowhere to
live so the government found some empty
space and in a matter of months built
Quonset huts for six thousand people all
for a total cost of what in today's
dollars would be less than 18 million
well that was then in the bond measure
we passed in 2016 to build housing for
the homeless
each unit was projected to cost a
hundred and forty thousand dollars which
is more than the asking price for this
four-bedroom Dutch colonial in Little
Falls New York and now that we're
actually building these apartments the
cost for each unit has risen to 531 K
how is that possible you may ask who
they each come with a lambo and a shark
tank
of course they still make those Quonset
huts and one today would cost about 8
grand but it's hard to skim money off 8
grand but five hundred and thirty one
thousand share but forty percent of that
cost goes to something the city calls
soft costs and I call [ __ ] costs
layer upon layer of middlemen inspectors
contractors lawyers lobbyists and oh yes
labor unions - and my favorite
consulting out of consulting going on in
America these days everyone seems to
need consulting apparently nobody in
America anymore knows what the [ __ ]
they're doing so we need consultants to
come in and be paid to tell you how to
do the job you're supposed to do
oh and until the 531 thousand dollar
apartments are built we're putting
special porta-potties near the homeless
camps which cost three hundred and
twenty thousand each for porta-potties
that's some good [ __ ] and California
finally conceded it needed to scale back
our big high speed rail project because
it was costing two hundred million
dollars a mile as opposed to France
we're building high-speed rail costs
thirteen million a mile but it's not
like France is cheap or doesn't have
labor unions France is nothing but labor
unions they have strikes like we have
mass shootings what they don't have is
this level of systematic graft and greed
the Donald Trump certainly represents
many of the ills our country has been
living with for a long time but perhaps
none more than that America is now scam
Erica the money should say in gouge we
trust on it
a vial of insulin costs about five
dollars to produce and is sold for over
500 y for the same reason it costs 8
bucks to get Pringles out of the minibar
because they can
why if it won Philadelphia Clinic they
can do a colonoscopy for a grand does
another one in the same city charge four
grand
I guess the price comes out of their ass
there is a breaking point in an economy
when the scam parasites killed the host
and we're coming up to that point so
before we finish rooting out corruption
Ukraine and what we take a swing at it
here in America
you